Japanese work culture man it's horrible
it's the worst it's the worst yeah
um you will be there sometimes six days
a week if not seven you will do things
outside of the scope of your contract
routinely and you are expected to go and
socialize with co-workers and be a part
of these things whether it's today we're
going to Proctor tests for eight hours
and in Japan that means you do not move
you do not speak you cannot check your
phone and if a student knocks like their
pencil off the table of their desk they
can't even pick it up you have to go and
be like here you are you can't speak
though you just ominously throw it down
on their face so these happen like six
or seven times a year with testing so
those are like weeks of your life where
you're sitting yeah and just thinking
and there's nothing worse than being
left alone with your thoughts on like a
beautiful day yeah so I've never thought
about that I uh yeah because like I I
can remember taking tests in like school
and stuff and I can't remember what my
teachers were doing well it was they
would hire examiners oh they were like
they were like third parties uh people
because obviously the teachers are
teaching still during exams so they
can't they can't oversee the exams oh so
we have like a whole testing block so
it'd be like all right it's finals or
university entrance examination kind of
pre-test yeah so all the teachers have
no classes but we take a buddy system
right and you'd sit there for night
stand there for 90 minutes and just
make sure no one's cheating and it's
like man this is brutal and uh those
things are like today we're having a
satsume Kai which is like an
informational day because we got to
recruit students so everyone down to the
arena so we can set up 475 chairs
manually you know like setting these
things and pulling them out of the thing
and then you do all this stuff like
waiting and in Japan you're like
you say that like 4 000 times I come
this way and then if you don't know
where the [__] the entrance is it's not
just the entrance you guide them along
like 18 people are pointing you to like
oh my God a straight line and you're
like okay and they always put the you
know they put me out front because I got
a winning smile and uh Hey welcome to
the parents are just like walking by and
you're like okay um but those outside of
the teaching stuff is a major part of
your work and you'll sit in meetings
legitimately for six or seven hours and
you have no idea what's being talked
about yeah and I'll lean over to like an
English teacher I'm like what are we
talking about she's like they're
discussing sock colors and I'm like what
we've been here for three hours I was
like purple blue
and they're just like no this is a very
important discussion so we it it's those
things Amplified times a hundred what
are they like trying to figure out the
[__] hexadecimals so the the shift
would be hard anyway having to do it and
on top of that you have hours upon hours
of time where you just feel like your
time is being wasted and unbelievably so
yeah because like I I interned at a
Japanese tech company during college for
like three months uh in Tokyo like in
Shibuya right
um and those three months were more than
enough time for me to be like I do not
want to be part of this cycle because it
was exactly the same like I had when I
was employed like I had like a set list
of things that was my job like
day-to-day basis right it's like you
know I did like website design like SEO
design and stuff like that but ninety
percent of the day was [__] that I had a
no expertise in or B I had no knowledge
in so I was like forced to like sit with
like these clients for this company and
they're talking about some kind of
[__] higher end business [__] and I'm
just sitting there being like
do you want me to like take notes and
they're like no no just be here why am I
here I could I could have finished my
job today by now if I didn't have this
meeting so it's like no no you have to
be here it's company policy I'm like is
it because I'm not [__] doing
anything
and that is the reality it's horrible
it's also he speaks Japanese so yeah I'm
just sitting there and it's like I have
I hate when people say I have ADHD right
but I like literally have it like yeah
yeah I was like the first kid who had it
and the treatments like when we were
kids I remember
um my mom took me to like this ADHD
Specialists
they put you in all these different
pills which my mom I think was like I'll
just take those you don't need them and
I was like those are uppers aren't they
and I'm like okay but they they gave me
uh they gave me these headphones that
were like giant like 1970s cans yeah and
I had to listen to whales communicating
for like three hours a night to try to
calm your mind and I was like this is I
was like I thought that was just like a
meme no I am the meme so yeah I am
that's me holy [__] we did that we
haven't helped um I don't think I'm
stable
I think I I don't know what happened to
me but like I don't think it helps I was
like eight or nine and so I was a kid
and so like I had some real real issues
uh but my mom was very patient but like
you know the ADHD part of me when you're
sitting in a room for seven hours and
you can't read a book you can't you
can't oh my God you just have to sit
there so it did that actually helped me
more than the whales did because you
really learned to be totally patient
with like the opportunity but
I do feel bad I want to say one thing
really quick about teaching because I've
totally [__] on it for like 30 minutes
right teaching can be really fun it's in
the classroom is I think with high
school especially it can be really
satisfying and very rewarding and you
get to see some kids make like genuine
progress and I like preparing my own
lessons I like doing that stuff yeah um
though I did it for probably nine years
too long but I still think if that's the
job that gets you into a country you
want to be in whether it's Japan or
somewhere else I would I would take it
still I have no regrets over those
experiences that I have a lot I'm
leaving out all the funny stories but
like I mean you have a treasure yeah
those those experiences are definitely
they've helped me in so many different
ways but yeah my advice would be find
another outside the school's income
something to supplement it something
like um private lessons or if you have
some other skills you join a hobby that
pays somehow that will help you enjoy
your life in Japan more than the the
working 75 hours a week yeah but yeah
those are all very different experiences
but they're all very it was a it's
pretty [__] on by everybody most people
if you ask them like what do you do in
Japan they'll be like
um
I I teach English but I also teach yoga
once every three months that's awesome
but you know we kind of meme it up a bit
to each other it's kind of like uh you
know we're like ah another day teaching
English you know it's it's tough yeah
that's what I see I think it's pretty
it's pretty mocked so how did you go
like
um how did you go and dump your process
of like planning lessons and stuff like
that was you did you just like make it
up on the floor like you probably have
to like follow a curriculum basic plan
right we have a curriculum or something
to follow you so it varies depending on
the school but I'll give you like two or
three examples sometimes the curriculum
is 100 either faxed to you from the
company like today's colors you know
um and it'll be like this is the layout
this is the intro this is the middle or
the or you'll have a giant book that has
a this is the sequence of lessons we're
teaching this year today's lesson is
this yeah um and then the other ones
that's step one that's usually like an a
Kiowa or Elementary School
it's pretty simplified and
straightforward yeah second one is like
I would say the Middle School area where
you have or early High School like eat
first-year students you work very
closely with an English teacher who is
their Japanese primary the Japanese
teacher who teaches English that makes
sense yeah okay sorry then they will say
you know I'm really I've taught them
this grammar point but I'm having
trouble making an activity so that we
could reuse it or like make it fun so
then you're like okay well let me uh let
me see what I got let me put on the
clown shoes real quick
it's like Superman but you just have the
buttons that are different things and I
start putting on the makeup uh those are
yeah you the common ones are like a
bingo or a Jeopardy or some sort of
interactive dialogue or you know and
then when you get into High School one
of my favorite things was I actually
well if I must admit I made my own
textbook thank you
and it never got published but you know
I got to use it in the class that I
taught but for me it was the perfect
opportunity because they said we've
created a class just for you we want you
to teach these students but we we're
leaving it open-ended to you but I need
you to write up a a detailed like yearly
outline like what is your your pedagogy
what are you gonna try to bring to them
what are the midterms what are the
finals how is it being all that stuff
right and I I really used my previous
six years of teaching and it was really
kind of nice to be able to put all of
those ideas into one single package and
so yeah as you get more experience and I
think if you take it seriously you have
a lot more control over how you want
those lessons to go but sometimes you
can tell immediately you get in there
and you're like oh I got the best game
ever we're gonna play this cool rock
scissors paper game and like 10 minutes
later you're like this shit's horrible
and no one's having fun you look at the
clock and you're like that wasn't even
two minutes I was three I got 47 more
minutes and then you're like all right
clean up clean up everybody everywhere
that this [__] always works so you learn
a lot about which I think has helped me
in acting definitely ha that degree was
useful yeah you know being agile or
being able to think on your feet and
improvising improvising is a massive one
and it's kind of cool you get this you
talk to teachers who've done it for a
while you get this internal clock where
you you don't even need to see the thing
anymore like on the wall you already
know that that's that game has already
been long enough yeah so let's let's
wrap it up and go to this other thing
and if I need to add or detract some
time no it's awesome it's a really fun
feeling being you know the your own
little star of a classroom it's fun oh
yeah but that's that's how you make a
lesson yeah